I have one job making the best clothing
in the world my name is Martin
Greenfield it used to be Maximillian
groom felt when I was born but me I
changed it to me that America because I
love this country
my craft is very difficult to define
because it's many things I am a maker of
clothing I know how to measure I know
how to fit people very few people could
match me I was responsible for all the
presidents Clinton I measured in the
White House Obama measured in the White
House so then I made up for fractures we
never had to fix nothing
my life is a sad life before I came to
America because I lost my family I was
left alone everybody was dead
we were occupied ouch which was a month
later I was in the concentration camp a
year and two months it was my second day
in Auschwitz there's no more names
because the Thracian kept only numbers
when they called me they sent me to
Terrell the head they ever spoke my
language he was Jewish they asked me are
you a tailor no I said if you could show
me how to make the color
he says I'll make you a car should we
have my car
the pain is still at my heart about my
family I still dream about my family
like they're alive but on the outside
you will never know I didn't think I was
gonna survive I was liberated by Eisner
General Eisenhower came in when I was
fifteen and a half years old and when
they worked in I shook us in crying you
saved my life
I came to America September 18 1947 they
gave me the job as a tailor I told my
boss listen
Eisenhower liberated me I want you to
make him a three-piece suit like I wear
myself he liked it once he had the first
three-piece suit from then on you didn't
see Eisenhower and nothing but
three-piece suits so that's how I
started
I made sure we dressed all the
presidents with Obama first he wanted me
to copy a suit I don't copy anybody
everybody copies my suit so if he wants
me to make something I have to measure
next day he sends her name it would be a
pleasure to meet you that I'm happy when
I'm at the factory my job is the most
important thing in my life quality is so
important to me
because I know that's what kept me in
business and that's why I'm here talking
to you
[Music]
you
[Music]